so I'm Sergi I work in a very small
consultancy it has three people we do
machine learning yeah it's a good name
all right thank you okay so I'm gonna
this is a sales pitch basically but
instead of for a company it's for a
methodology so probably all of you have
heard of cross-validation then some of
you may use it so I'm gonna cover why
that's good and then use that to
motivate Nesta cross-validation which
should be more popular so I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna convince you that that's
the case this is a machine learning talk
so I'm gonna take out a piece of the
machine learning pipeline and talk about
some goals that matter to this talk so
there's two goals that I care about like
if you do a lot on machine learning and
you already have some models that you
fit for hyper parameter validation or
you just want to compare some models
then you need to choose one that's best
and go with it and put it into
production or make a case to somebody
about what that model is doing and the
second goal is you want to estimate how
good that model is going to be when you
put it into production so it turns out
that these two goals are okay this now
has stopped
okay these two goals are both necessary
but to do them simultaneously is
difficult for reasons that I'll explain
shortly and nested cross-validation is
exclusively to make goal two better so
it's not going to help you choose models
better it's just gonna use that to give
you a better estimate of how good your
model is gonna be that's more reliable
and more something that you're gonna
want to have so here's what it really
can't see most of the plot here okay
there's no don't worry about it so this
is an optimistic version of what machine
learning is like you get some data it's
one dimensional here which is really not
true and then you get some outputs and
you have a real function which you've
never seen before it's in red and you
know you get these samples and you fit a
line through it and it works really well
and this is a complete lie don't but
this is what we use to motivate our life
so that we fit them all to this data but
usually we fit a bunch of models to data
and and you know sometimes they're bad
in different ways so this model is under
fit we should use the polynomial use the
linear model this model is over fit we
should have used a three or four order
polynomial we instead use something like
twelve order and you know but so usually
you don't have these nice plots so you
have to programmatically choose the best
model you can't just eyeball it and the
goal is to choose a model that
generalizes and Wow this doesn't have a
lot of range okay so I have to stand
here so it turns out that training error
is really misleading and training error
is when you take the training samples
you have and evaluate your your the
model that you fit maybe it can detect
under fitting so here the training error
is really large and you can tell that
it's a bad model but what it can't do is
it can't detect overfitting because it
you know you're evaluating the data used
to fit so the model fits that data
really well so to do that you need to
just hold out some of your data so this
is the first thing you do you hold out
some of your data for evaluation
purposes to help you choose a model and
here's how that works you start with a
whole bunch of data you split it up if
the data has no structure you split it
up randomly if it's a time series you
split it up by time so this is you know
Monday through Friday and this is
Saturday Sunday you fit some model on
your training data and then you evaluate
your model on the validation data
all very standard and then you do this
for five models and you decide that the
model with the lowest error is the best
model and now you run into a little
problem which is this point for error is
actually not a good estimate of how good
that model is and to understand that we
have to recall what our goals are and
why they're interfering with each other
so the first goal is select the best
model which we just did and what I just
showed here is a completely legitimate
way to select a model so that's not a
problem
the problem is that we want to estimate
how best how well the best model
generalizes and when we try to do that
we we can't do both at the same time so
this we can't use the point for and the
reason is because that error estimate is
biased and the nature of this bias is a
little tricky and the reason it's biased
is because it's the lowest error we
found so we took the minimum and then we
said the minimum is a bad estimate so
each of these individually is a good
estimate of their model but the minimum
is not a good estimate of the of the
true lowest model and to understand that
we have to think of generalization error
as a random variable so imagine these
are distributions of the generalization
error of four different models in some
sense the mean of these distributions is
the true generalization error so you
have these three models a through C that
have the exact same generalization error
they just have different variances and
what makes you get a different sample it
depends what draw the data you get so
there's a true but you know infinite
data set which we don't have and instead
we take samples from that data set and
thus we get samples from this curve so
really what we want to know is which
curve has the smallest mean and to do
that we take a sample and to do that we
cut up our data so here's one example of
a sample okay so we sampled this blue
line this red line the yellow line and
the green line and in this case
everything worked out really well is we
sampled the Green Line and it happens to
be the lowest and we chose that one and
it looks like the Green Line is a pretty
good estimate of the mean so if we do
find the correct model then we actually
have a good estimate of the
generalization error however that's not
always the case right sometimes we do
something like this okay now this is now
the yellow line happen to be the lowest
one which is wrong but it's possible
because we have randomness
and look at this this is a terrible
estimate of the mean of the yellow line
so if you use the lowest error as an
estimate of that models error in case
that's the wrong one you're making a
horrible mistake and when that this
model goes into production you're
probably gonna get something closer to
here just by chance so we can't use the
held-out error to estimate
generalization it's dangerous for these
reasons so if you if you get it right
it's fine but if you don't it's really
dangerous and oftentimes we get it wrong
because we don't know what these are how
these are actually shaped we don't know
the variance so we have to hedge our
bets and the way to hedge your bet
properly oh I guess we don't need that
is to do a test data split also so this
is this is actually the most traditional
way to evaluate your models you have
training validation and test set you
apply all four models on the training
set one at a time you apply all four
validation all four models on the
validations at one at a time you choose
the one with the lowest error and then
you apply only that model on the test
data okay now this is a completely
legitimate way to both choose a model
with the validation data and assess its
generalization performance with the test
data and here's some scikit-learn code
to show you how easy this is you do a
bunch of imports pretty standard you
load up a toy data set you can stick
your own data set in here and it'll work
fine here we have to remember we have to
have three different splits right so we
need training validation and test
there's a function called train test
split which if you give it a data set
it'll cut it up into two parts so we
have to call it twice to get three parts
so first we cut up x and y which is the
features and your output into something
that has both training and validation
and just tests then we take what has
training and validation and we cut it up
again into training and validation now
we have these three sets like I
described and in this case we're
comparing four random forest classifiers
but you can stick whatever you want in
here and what differentiates them is
their maximum depth so it's a for loop
for each of the maximum depth I fit a
random forest classifier you know I fit
it on the training data only I get its
error and I store it so that's just very
simple then I find the best one
so here this is the model selection step
right I'm not evaluating the
generalization I don't actually care
what the error value is because it's
biased but down here I refit the random
forest using the best step on the
training and validation together and
this is my test error so again this is
develop the validation that is used to
select the model and here I says this
generalization performance on the test
site that was not seen during these two
portions that's just an example of the
code example of the of the figure that I
showed over there okay so we what we
haven't done is accounted for the
variance which you saw in the width of
the various Gaussian as I showed of the
fact that we're taking this random split
so if I instead of doing this if I do
this what happens do I get it different
do I get a different model does I mean
is that important I mean it could be
potentially important if the variability
is very large so this is what people
talk about cross-validation instead of
just doing one split they do a bunch of
splits to account for that variance and
if you take multiple samples from that
Gaussian you'll get a better estimate of
the mean so let's take five full
cross-validation this five is just an
example and go through what it does in
the same kind of framework so our tools
here are just the training data and the
test set we haven't done the validation
split and we get some model so you you
split it up five times before we just
had this upper row that was what we had
in the previous of figure we had a born
validation split and all this training
but now we do it five different ways so
each sample participates and as part of
the validation fold at least once
actually here it's exactly once but
whatever and then we fit the model the
same model five different times and we
get five different errors and now we
have five samples and we just average
them and bats are now way to choose a
model instead of having just one we have
five so we're doing a better job less
variance and this is what it looks like
overall so so far the test set hasn't
been used there if you notice so we have
this box I'm going to call it k-fold
cross-validation box I just showed you
how it works
you give it all the models you want they
all go through a careful cross
validation procedure then you have a
selection criteria which says what's the
best cross validation error but we don't
trust the cable across validation here
for
same reason I described before so we
decide what it should be on the test set
which we haven't seen yet that's it so
this is this is capable cross-validation
it's very popular everyone uses it and
this is kind of where people usually
stop so let's take a look at the the
code for this it's even easier because
scikit-learn is really good at giving
you tools to simplify complicated data
splits and model evaluations so imagine
we have all the imports from before now
we don't have to split into training a
validation and test we just have train
and test we import this thing called
grid search CV which does our cross
validation for us this is the parameter
grid here which again the random forests
with four different depths we
instantiate the random forest and then
we give the grid search CV our random
forest or whatever model you want and a
parameter grid in this five because
we're doing five volt cross-validation
and you fit it and when you say fit it
does the splitting and the fitting for
you and does everything you want and
then at the end we retrain on all of the
training data using the best parameters
this is a little bit of black magic
where you just get the best parameters
from this cross-validation grid search
thing and you just retrain so this is
the example to do grit to do
cross-validation so this is the second
way to do things so we I just made a
case that you have to do
cross-validation because you have
validation set variance and using the
exact same argument we can make the case
you should be doing something else
because you have test set variance right
now we still have only a single test set
so the argument sort of makes itself is
you know what happens if we'd use it
ever in test set I mean what did we get
a different model do we get different
generalization performance it's kind of
unclear so basically just do what I just
did in another way this why it's called
nested because you're doing another for
loop on top of the for loop which is
doing and it's very straightforward so
this is called four fold outer K fold
inner CV so we had five folds
cross-validation but you also need to
split up your test set okay so this is
how you do it blue blocks our training
goal block is testing so we instead
before we just had this this is the only
thing we had before now we're just going
to do all the samples are going to
participate in the test set instead of
just whatever twenty percent we
happened to reserve and if you remember
we had this slide before you took the
blue blocks that was a training data you
gave it to a k-fold cross-validation
block you tested all the models he
wanted you did model selection using
this cross validation error and then you
did model generalization assessment
using the test set well the I mean the
story just basically writes itself
you're just everything's the same you
just use a different set of blocks to
decide what you're doing and now maybe
you're choosing a different model which
is kind of weird because before we had
one model I'll talk about that in a
minute but you just do this four times
okay so we just what do we just do we
just repeated our entire procedure four
times this could be ten times you know
that you can sort of decide that based
on what it is you're doing and what did
we gain and what does it mean and who
makes these things all right so if we do
an outer KN or nested CV on M models
then we have to fit a total of n by K
times M time so if you're just doing
cross-validation it's just K by M times
so the price you pay for this is you
multiply all your computation by n so
maybe if you're spending five hours you
have to spend 20 hours which may be
unacceptable to you however they're both
embarrassingly parallel so if money is
not the issue it's just computation then
you can just pay four times more to get
something that's considerably a better
estimate of both what models you should
be choosing and also how good they are
so it may be nowadays is not that big of
a deal
and what is it good for I mean I sort of
alluded to this earlier but I think it's
important to think is you know with K
fold TV what do we get we got one model
and we got a assessment with
generalization performance
now we're getting something weird we're
getting as many models as we have test
set splits which might be different ones
and we have four assessments of the
generalization performance so before I
got one model like I just put that in
production and say this is the best
model now since I have four test sets
those could be four different models
which is a little confusing you have to
sort of decide do what do i do do I put
them all into production you know um
it's it's not clear but there's a lot of
good options let's say those models are
very different one of them is random
forests and one's a linear model you
could just put the linear model in the
production because I obviously they're
animal forest isn't that much
because it would have otherwise done as
well on that particular split so it
gives you some flexibility but you have
to make more decisions and requires a
higher level of understanding of what
your models are doing and again it's you
know it so what do we just do we got
four estimates of generalization
performance instead of one not only do
we have a better idea how good it is
because four samples is better than one
we also have a notion of variance which
we didn't really have before so you can
you can have more idea of how the model
might fail in production which before we
really didn't know we just have one
sample which is a very limited
information and what do we do with the
best models
I just like to ensemble them it's kind
of a hedging your bed type of thing you
have four models they're different they
probably have different high parameters
do you ensemble them you're sort of
guaranteeing some amount of robustness
against different types of data that you
might encounter in the wild if they're
very different then you're guaranteeing
more robustness if they're all very
similar then you know that the model is
particularly doing a good job so there's
different things you can do here and
that's only feasible if your production
environment can handle you know
something that's multiplying the number
of miles you have by three or four which
not everyone never none of them not all
them can deal with so let's take a look
at the code for this it's even easier
because like I said it's like the more
complicated thing you want to do the
less code you have to do in scikit-learn
so you have your imports same before
load your data same as before you define
your random forest classifier identical
here is your parameter grid the same and
these two lines do nested
cross-validation for you the first line
is as before give your grid search TV it
takes in your estimator your parameter
grid and your cross-validation number so
five and then this is the sort of magic
part is the cross Valspar function when
you give it an estimator instead of
giving it like a model or a classifier
you actually give it the grid search CV
and tell it to do four fold cross
validation over the full data set and it
does nested cross validation for you so
this is all the code so the complexity
isn't really in the coding and this is
the result that you get here depending
on your random seed so these are the
errors so basically the errors are from
zero which because this is a joke data
set to 6% so imagine this was your
actual life and you happen to
this test said you would have a vastly
optimistic notion of what test
performance you can expect this is by
chance and this now tells you some
notion of variance so you could imagine
in any of your applications where you
have a single test set you could be
landing on any any one of these numbers
or in between them so really you should
do this if you can afford it and I'm on
the idea of affording it I presented
three legitimate types of validation and
they are not all possible in all cases
so here's like a little cheat sheet of
when you should use them so if your data
is small as in really small you should
always use nested cross-validation you
basically there's basically no reason
not to and it only has advantages like
an Y small I mean medical data a couple
thousand patients maybe fifty features
one hundred features something that
really is is relatively small if you
have medium data something I would say
hundred thousand rows and one hundred
thousand maybe a thousand features then
it sort of depends on what you're doing
if your models are fast maybe from
scikit-learn or XG boost not then you
probably can do it if you can wait two
days but you might not be able to in
case your models are something like deep
learning which is much slower or maybe
you just don't have a compute so then
you just do regular cross validation not
nested cross validation and in the big
data regime people don't do cross
validation at all they have a single
training validation test split because
they have five million samples and you
just kind of train only on this validate
only on this and test only on this and
people are satisfied with this because
everything else is impractical unless
your Google or something so this is kind
of what you should be doing and really
what I'm speaking to is the audience
that has this kind of situation I deal a
lot with medical datasets and I've
always found that nessa cross validation
gives you a really good additional
insight into what the data is doing and
to what the model is doing and has no
downside so it's a hundred percent win
there's no hidden costs you will do no
side effects it's great so that is the
end thanks
thank you we have time for questions
you you mentioned the the embarrassingly
parallel nature of all of this
cross-validation so I think you can just
specify right in the the estimator the
number of workers right if into the
estimator then you're paralyzing just
the estimator but you're fitting
multiple ones of them so so you have to
so it's still serial that each estimator
is paralyzed if it can be like a random
forest but then you're still doing it in
serial so if you but you could paralyze
further if you have multiple machines
you can't use the magic that they use is
there you sort of make your own test
sets and send it different machines but
yeah okay I was just gonna ask if you
knew of any nice pipelines that made
that uh not really you can always rod
that top my head okay thank you would
you suggest that once you have the data
set that you're working with and you
understand the shape of the data that
you're dealing with would you suggest
that this kind of technique will be more
helpful if you if you are unsure of the
variance in the data set that you have
or would you recommend this with any
regular practice that when we're running
models yeah I think the latter because
you you don't know the variance of the
model and the data so you you might have
a data set that you're very familiar
with you might not have any idea how
what happens when you fit the model the
model could be very high variance
depending you know maybe one sample
difference in your model does something
vastly different so that could happen
because the models behave unpredictably
on data there's there's so many ways to
combine it thank you
initially alluded to the the costs for
doing cross-validation in terms of big
data doing validation on big data so why
not just take say a small data sample
size of the data set perform cross
validation to get a idea of the best
model or I guess what I'm basically
trying to access how would you select
the best model when you're dealing with
a when you're doing a it's trying to
find a model for big data itself yeah so
here what people are relying on here and
this is not necessarily the case is that
if you have really huge amounts of data
than even the validation split is very
large okay and so that means that by the
idea is if this is large enough it
doesn't matter what's what I take
because it's just because remember a
validation error is like the sum over
all the samples in the validation set
the average over them so this is also a
mean that the validation error is the
mean so if the number goes up enough
you're like I don't care this is a good
estimate of the mean it doesn't matter
if I take a different sample so these
arguments are sort of big data arguments
if this is big enough one validation set
is sufficient and it bears out in
practice if your validation set is
representative of your entire set so
let's say you have a million samples
here but they're all from Tuesday and
the reality is all happening on Sunday
people don't behave the same way then
it's useless so you have to sort of
adhere to the assumptions of this of
this is that this is big enough to
capture the variability of your true
data set and you you know for like
imagenet it's true because it's an
artificial data set people collected it
and they randomized it and the puppies
and the validation look like the puppies
and the test set so everyone's happy but
as soon as you go out of this regime all
this falls apart completely but yeah so
that's the assumption it's big enough
any more questions
heuristic or experimental or even
analytic results for choosing inverse K
oh I do 10 and 10 it's expensive I mean
as large should you always go sort of
even numbers on each or does it make
sense to do like a 10-fold
cross-validation and only a three-fold
test so I'm worried about the following
and this is only semi empirical is hyper
parameters are a way of saying this
model on this data okay and so if your
data set gets much bigger maybe the
hyper parameters that worked on a
smaller subset of it don't work on a
bigger subset so when I use 10-fold
cross-validation the difference is 9/10
which is not that much if I do three
then it's 2/3 you know so I'm like oh
very well maybe this learning rate
doesn't work when I have more data or
something like that so to mitigate that
I try to have a large N and K so 10 and
10 but that gets expensive because
there's a hundred times number of models
number of models is 50 you so that's why
I you know I do it here and then it's
okay I sort of say it's okay to be lazy
for medium data because I just can't
wait that long it's it's not realistic
yeah thank you sir
[Applause]